er sollte der schönste tag in ihrem
leben werden die hochzeit des reifen
königs bruno google mit seiner corinna
in gammertingen in der nähe von
stuttgart feierte das paar mit
prominenten gästen eine pompöse party
als plötzlich das ganze firmengelände
lichterloh in flammen steht
was hier brennt ist das lebenswerk eines
reifen millionärs unglaublich der
unternehmer feierte gerade seine
hochzeit auf dem firmengelände als es
passierte gerade noch spielt dj ötzi auf
der bühne und plötzlich steht alles in
flammen die braut sie steht unter schock
fassungslos steht sie zwischen
einsatzfahrzeugen
rettungskräfte beruhigen
reifen könig bruno gangel heiratete
seine corinna beide geben ein
rauschendes fest auf dem firmengelände
in gammertingen in baden württemberg
der millionär ein bekannter unternehmer
sogar alt kanzlerin angela merkel war
schon zu besuch die hochzeit sollte ein
abend der extraklasse werden vor der
firmenzentrale ein vergoldeter mercedes
geländewagen mit roter schleife am
himmel formen jets von red bull ein herz
einem stück erdbeer hochzeitstorte
bestaunen die gäste das feuerwerk es
sollte die krönung der party werden es
endet in entfernung die hochzeitsfeier
des reifen millionärs mit 300 gästen
endet in einem desaster
gasflaschen explodieren fahrzeuge gehen
in flammen auf das firmengelände brennt
lichterloh auch eine gerade errichtete
lagerhalle mit verwaltungstrakt
15 menschen werden verletzt wir kommen
mit einer rauchgasvergiftung ins
krankenhaus
wegen der extremen rauchentwicklung wird
eine katastrophenmeldung ausgelöst
heute ist genau
wovon wir alle sowie handeln das
hoffentlich nie eintritt also es war
natürlich ein größerer brand deswegen
auch die vielen einsatzkräfte aus fiat
kreisen
die jetzt ihr bestes gegeben haben das
riesenfeuerwerk das highlight der
hochzeit die gäste schauen gebannt in
den himmel dann steht plötzlich alles in
flammen aus dem schillernden fest mit
ganz viel glanz wurde ein abend der
flammen der zerstörung und der tränen so
hatte sich der reifen millionär seine
traumhochzeit ganz sicher nicht
vorgestellt
unser bild reporter hagen stegmüller ist
für uns vor ort in gammertingen hagen
das feuerwerk sollte ja das highlight
dieser partie werden was ist dann
passiert was ist schiefgelaufen
ja gut morgen es war gegen 23 uhr 30 als
noch einmal ein feuerwerk den krönenden
abschluss bilden sollte dieser party und
offenbar die letzten drei vier raketen
müssen dann in einen reifenstapel
geflogen sein sodass uns geschildert den
unmittelbar nach dem ende des feuerwerks
bekannt dass weitere feuerwerk das
ungeplante hier lagern bis zu 1,5
millionen reifen die reifen haben einen
niedrigen flammpunkt haben sich offenbar
schnell entzündet und es war zwar eine
brandwache dort aber die könnte ich ja
gar nichts mehr machen und der brand
ging sofort durch und innerhalb von
sekunden uns wurde gesagt es ging alles
rasend schnell nach 23 minuten war ja
ein flammenmeer und den besuchern blieb
nichts anderes übrig als schnell in ihre
luxuslimousinen einzusteigen vom hof zu
fahren und der feuerwehr platz zu machen
aber hagen man fragt sich natürlich an
dieser stelle wie kann es sein dass dort
gasflaschen direkt neben einem feuerwerk
platziert werden haben die pyrotechniker
das nicht gesehen haben die
pyrotechniker versagt an dieser stelle
ja die gasflaschen stand sicherlich
nicht direkt neben den abschussort der
raketen sich dann eben wie es in einem
industriebetrieb
sportliches man braucht energie und das
sind auch gasflaschen vor ort gewesen
aber die gasflaschen sind nicht als
erstes explodiert die sind einfach dann
hochgegangen als die hitze durch die
entzündeten reifenstapel zu heiß wurde
dann können natürlich auch die
gasflaschen dieser hitze nicht mehr
standhalten das war praktisch noch so
die krönung dann hat es eben diese
schläge getan die meinen gammertingen
teilweise bis nach albstadt eben gehört
hat die gasflaschen waren letztlich
sicherlich nicht das problem es ist ja
auch niemand zu schaden gekommen
natürlich muss man generell sich fragen
warum man ein feuerwerk neben
hochentzündlichen reifen veranstaltungen
dann noch in dieser menge die
feuerwehrleute sprechen ja mal von
brandlasten wenn viel brennbare masse
vorhanden ist hier war extrem viel
vorhanden vielen dank wagen
stehengelassen
live ausgabe